the Special Air Service or SAS is a
special forces unit of the British Army
founded in 1941 this unit performs a
number of roles including covert
reconnaissance counterterrorism direct
action and hostage rescue the SAS was
established to assist in highly
classified more unconventional
operations during World War two in 1945
the war was over the British government
saw no further need for the force and
the unit was disbanded but within a year
it was decided that there was a need for
a long-term commando unit and the SAS
regiment was re-established in 1947 the
majority of information and actions
regarding the SAS is highly classified
and is not disclosed by the British
government or Ministry of Defence due to
the sensitivity of their operations
effect it wasn't until 1980 that the SAS
gained notoriety worldwide after the
televised hostage rescue during the
Iranian embassy siege after the
reactivation of Team rainbow in 2015 for
SAS commanders were recruited to bring
their skills and expertise and to assist
in the fight against terrorism on a
global scale these commandos were called
sledge fetcher mute and smoke
[Music]
[Music]
you
sheamus Khaldun codenamed sledge is an
attacking operator in team rainbow born
and raised in the Scottish Highlands
sleeches of physical presence that
demands retention and respect in his
younger days he was the captain of the
1998 Scotland national under-20 strug B
team he has a strong desire for public
service and went on to enlist in the
army at the age of 18 after five years
of duty he was recruited by the SAS to
this day sleep still holds the all-time
speed and strength record for the SAS
qualifying physical exam selita's
professionalism and technical abilities
are top tier and made him an integral
member of the SAS he was expected to
perform at the absolute highest level in
his new role as a rainbow operator he is
identified as an incredibly imposing
self-assured and athletic individual
there is a certain wildness to his
personality which no doubt has been
shaped by the rugged terrain he's born
into a proud and stoic Scottish meant
though he genuinely acknowledges that he
can be a little hot-headed at times an
enthusiastic and Evitts storyteller he
enjoys reminiscing about the good old
days and is thrilled when he finds an
eager ear who would listen to his tales
eternally mischievous and a thrill
seeker he recalls a particular account
of when he was 12 years old when he
managed to construct his own hand glider
out of boat sails and launched himself
off his roof not surprisingly he broke
both ankles
[Music]
in regards to tails during his military
training here accounts a time where it
accidentally collapsed his entire
barracks leaving quarters while testing
out a new breaching technique on another
occasion he decided to commandeer his
captain's mode bike and proceeded to
write it off the pier because he wanted
to see how far it would travel on the
surface not fiery admitted as it sank
quickly after overall seizures and
easygoing unpretentious operator though
he gets ruffled at the mention of
politics a self-proclaimed news junkie
he doesn't shy away from debates in fact
it's one of the main reasons he joined
the military always a true professional
while on assignment he understands that
rainbow operators refrained from voicing
their political opinions to keep the
peace and so far there's been no issues
regarding this
however it's not to say the distant
speakers peace especially after a few
beers down at the pub have used the
other operators in the SAS as family
most notably vector in particular who he
acknowledges convinced him to switch to
the cable a large number of rainbow
operators refer to sleet as one of the
easiest teammates to repeat a number of
field reports illustrate its leadership
courage and extensive operational
experience though don't mistakenly
viewing is just another gentle giant as
is volatility still exists over time
sleech developed operational expertise
in breaking down barriers using a bridge
hammer his specialized technical
breaching hammer is known as the caper
and can breach through almost all
non-reinforced surfaces and barricades
with silently aggressive pace breaching
hand is nothing new to counterterrorism
law enforcement but what makes the caper
so unique is its exceptional size and
weight for most agents this would be
cumbersome and impractical
it's Luger's exceptional physical
prowess makes them a formidable presence
in the battlefield allowing for quick
and effective breaches
GPS satellites unmanned drones for King
laser sights the more crochon you have
the more ears when they kicked out from
under yet
if there's one thing I know for sure if
the de six-inch blade never loses
reception Mike Baker codenamed Thatcher
is an attacking operator in team rainbow
from Biddeford England he comes from a
family of dock workers when his 18th
birthday he enlisted for active military
duty a veteran of three wars Thatcher
was the oldest SAS operative on active
duty until he was recruited by Team
rainbow he selection at the Battle of
goose green during the Falklands
conflict he was involved in the rescue
operation of the Iranian embassy siege
in 1980 and he was a veteran of the Gulf
War
Thatcher's performance on and off the
battlefield and during two major
political conflicts made him a natural
fit for VIP protection duty he is highly
proficient in close quarters combat and
is a will caliber expert in anti
electronics operations Thatcher is
highly observant calculating and
decisive while he may come off as a bit
grumpy and impatient his profound sense
of ethical responsibility it's
recommended to assign Thatcher with
junior operators of strong moral
conviction of whom he could mentor
raised in a coastal town is a strong
affiliation with the water
Thatcher enjoys crafting things with his
hands and what he most appreciates about
boat building is shaping the wood into
something that has a purpose some
suggest the so he mentors recruits he is
a dip too bringing out their natural
abilities a true salt of the earth
individual he'll tell it like it is
which can often come across as being
gruff and abrupt getting to know him
requires some effort however it's worth
it in the long run as he is a highly
sought-after and well respected
individual it should come as no surprise
that he's extremely cynical towards the
government and has a higher version
towards technology though it's not to
say that he can't figure it out it's
just that to him technology is just a
tool like a hammer or a screwdriver and
the idea that so many people come to
rely on it as a crutch greatly annoys
him Thatcher has a remarkable background
in military and is a deeply respected
individual in some cases idolized by
those he mentors Silesian home get along
extremely well and he considers him one
of his very close friends surprisingly
he also has a large amount of respect
for mute even though he usually has
prising low tolerance for young whipper
snippers and seems almost envious of him
at times conversationally admitting that
he thinks mute is a clever kid this may
be due to the younger man's exceptional
skills with technology or even because
he echoes someone who Thatcher wishes he
could have been we're not on assignment
thatcher lives in a boat yard aboard his
vessel IM maggie who he enjoys repairing
in his spare time
maggie is his retirement plan as after
his divorce was finalized he found
himself without a home he plans to
eventually live out his days on the sea
thatcher is equipped with EG mko EMP
grenades when thrown they'll lit up an
electromagnetic pulse after a few
seconds either destroying or disabling
all electronics within a 5 meter radius
the EMP is efficiency and empty
electronic warfare has been known and
studied since the early 60s team
rainbows engineers recently made a
breakthrough and solving the problem of
creating a localized fission reaction
while keeping the gamma radiation to
tolerable levels resulting in the eg mko
EMP grenade a personal handheld device
known as more suited to wilt this novel
device vendetta known for his warnings
against over reliance on technology
mark Chandler codenamed mute is a
defending operator and team rainbow born
in York England you graduated from
secondary school at the age of 12 a
child prodigy he went on to complete an
internship at a British tech company
where he worked on prototypes for a new
security system and then at the ripe old
age of 14 he was accepted into the
University of Cambridge mute is highly
intelligent and analytical he's used to
being the smartest person in the room a
man of few words
it prefers to be short and concise when
passing information and because of this
is often misread as being rude it isn't
immediately clear where his code name is
mute though he disliked a small talk
he isn't particularly reserved an effect
can be quite brash a trait that is
off-putting to some he can be somewhat
impatient and this can be noticed in
social interactions and he can often
struggle to shake it off when in this
frame of mind Thatcher is surprisingly
tolerant of this trait and will often
speak up in mutes defense he is drawn to
certain personalities ones that have a
more abstract way of thinking operator
glass is a similar talent to seeing
complex situations in a unique way
given mutes background and information
security he understands secrecy and
seems uncomfortable with expressing
himself with personal questions in his
field here at Rainbow information is a
critical life-and-death commodity
Muse's equipped with 4g c90 money signal
disruptors which are portable devices
which could be placed on the floor to
jam attackers electronic devices in a
wider area developed by britain's
government communications headquarters
the money was originally designed as a
portable device that could blackout
radio transmissions or communication
devices for covert or sensitive meetings
between British government officials and
foreign interests is one of the primary
engineers on the project mute created a
variant of this device there has doubled
the effective range of the original GCHQ
signal disruptor
I know what you're wondering what's in
the canister I could tell you but then
I'd have to kill you Amala machina BER
relax as for what's in the canister its
bested owner James Porter codenamed
smoke is a defending operator in team
rainbow smoke was not an academic but
though in secondary school he excelled
in science
he took a particular interest in biology
and especially the topic of dissection
during his gap year
Smoak enlisted in the British Army using
a fake ID in order to avoid getting
parental consent after basic training
smoke was stationed in Belfast but he
found the posting a bit dull in the
waking of the March 2007 treaty he went
on to join the army boxing team as the
middleweight smokers a thrill seeker
with very little guard for his own
safety he is fearless in battle and
could be a great asset for defensive
maneuvers however he seems to enjoy the
havoc and chaos savage so little bit too
much and has an odd sense of humor when
placed in stressful situations smokes
parents encouragement to be free spirit
to cultivate his own individual identity
and level of education on his own terms
when he deemed himself ready due to his
enlightened free range education that
helped create a complex dynamic person
who wasn't easily categorized even today
he enjoys acquiring new skills and once
he's mastered something he quickly moves
on to the next challenge
although very little is known about his
adopted daughter it's obvious that smoke
is proud of her the one photo he carries
around in his wallet showcases her as a
young infant surrounded by dangerous
paraphernalia now in high school she is
excelling and through her smoke is able
to see the world from a completely
different viewpoint smoke is
consistently described as detached and
withdrawn interestingly as most often
occurs during high-intensity situations
therefore it is likely not detachment
but pure focus enabling him to stay on
task and filter out any unnecessary
distractions
he strives to keep emotions away from
the decision-making opting for outlets
such as live music events to remove the
tension and enabling him to be the
person he needs to be while on the job
even though we can come across a little
reckless and a bit of a thrill-seeker
smokers appreciated by his unit and
considered an invaluable asset but
regardless smokers a deep understanding
respect to fear and believes rather than
trying to pretend we never feel it to
embrace it
smoke requested a portable device system
that could deliver the most damage to
intruders in a targeted area he was
equipped with compounds edate remote gas
grenades using a remote detonator smoke
and view the results from the distance
the mines are filled with the collection
biological chemicals that on their own
are inert but when combined have a more
volatile effect the resulting concoction
will damage will kill anyone exposed to
it even if the enemies are not caught in
the gas its thick enough to act as a
normal smoke grenade cloud blocking
vision in the area the original version
of this video was my first attempt at
covering the law of siege operators and
after a few subtle hints from the
community I realized a number of small
mistakes and large pieces of information
that are completely missed so it was
always the plan to update this one it
just took a little longer than expected
to get to it I'm thoroughly enjoying the
story behind these guys and I'm learning
a lot about the massive number of
Special Forces groups from around the
world
some I'd never heard of
in a way thank you very much for
watching I hope you've enjoyed this and
I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers